ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre la suite de la discussion
générale du projet de loi de réforme de
la garde à vue à mes côtés pour en
parler françois zocchetto président du
groupe centriste ici au sénat et
rapporteur de ce texte bonjour
il a fallu attendre que la france soit
condamnée par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour qu'elle se
saisisse de cette question de la garde à
vue comment on peut expliquer le retard
de la france en la matière le débat
n'est pas nouveau et au sénat depuis
deux ans maintenant nous avons eu de
nombreuses séances qui ont été consacrés
à la réforme de la garde à vue
pour nous cette réforme est inévitable
nous la demandions depuis longtemps et
nous sommes très satisfaits que le
gouvernement ait déposé un texte pour
réformer la garde à vue
d'ailleurs une des avancées un principal
de ce sex et donc la présence d'un
avocat
donc pour la personne gardée à vue
pendant son audition mais il y avait
également un autre problème en france à
savoir le nombre considérable de garde à
vue que prévoit le texte pour réduire le
nombre de garde à vue actuellement les
parlementaires et l'opinion publique se
sont émus du nombre croissant de garde à
vue puisque en 2009 nous avons eu à peu
près 800 mille gardes à vue c'est un
chiffre tout à fait anormal et il était
urgent que cette situation cesse alors
désormais si le texte est voté
la garde à vue sera réservé aux
infractions susceptibles de d'une peine
d'emprisonnement alors qu'auparavant les
contraventions et tous les délits
pouvait donner lieu à une garde à vue
donc je pense que
cela va diminuer le nombre de gardes à
vue le deuxième point très important
c'est que désormais la personne qui est
en garde à vue pourra bénéficier de
l'assistance d'un avocat alors que
jusqu'à présent cette assistance
n'existait pas vraiment puisqu'il y
avait juste une visite qu'on appelait à
une espèce de visite de courtoisie de 30
minutes maximum de l'avocat les
conditions également d'encadrement de la
garde à vue vont être améliorés que
prévoit le texte fort cette amélioration
alors le texte prévoit aussi que les
victimes qui sont confrontés à l'auteur
des faits pourront bénéficier désormais
d'un avocat
alors que ça c'est ce en vertu du
principe de l'égalité des armes
le contrôle de la garde à vue restera
assurée par un magistrat en l'occurrence
le procureur jusqu'à la 48e menant
ensuite si une personne doit être
maintenu en garde à vue elle sera
obligatoirement présenter à un juge
alors il ya un point sensible à savoir
la suppression de l'audition libre c'est
ce qui a été décidé par les députés
pourtant certains sénateurs craignent
que l'audition libre soit réintroduite
dans ce texte à travers l'article 11 bis
alors qu'en est il exactement
ils ont tort de craindre cette
réintroduction de l'audition libre ne
voulons pas de l'audition libre pas plus
les sénateurs que que les députés
néanmoins il ya des circonstances dans
lesquelles une personne peut librement
accepté d'être interrogé sur des faits
et là il est bien normal que le texte
prévoit dans quelles conditions cette
personne plus librement accepté d'être
interrogé par les services de police ou
de gendarmerie
il ya très bien merci françois zocchetto
d'avoir répondu aux questions de public
sénat je vous laisse regagner à
l'hémicycle tout de suite donc la suite
de la discussion générale très bonne
science à vous alors nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relatif à la garde
à vue dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à notre collègue
françois pinet qui rattachait à l'ump
pour 14 minutes
seul président monsieur le garde des
sceaux seul rapporteur une chaire
collègues pour la première fois depuis
la révision constitutionnelle du 23
juillet 2008
notre assemblée saisi d'un projet de loi
qui vise à tirer les conséquences d'une
décision rendue dans le cadre d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité par le conseil
constitutionnel en abrogeant le support
légal de la garde à vue tout en
renvoyant les effets de sa décision au
1er juillet prochain le conseil
constitutionnel a plus largement mis le
législateur en demeure de définir un
nouvel équilibre entre les droits de la
défense et la protection de l'ordre
public au cours d'une mesure
progressivement devenu un symbole de l'
enquête policière
le 1er juillet prochain nous serons dans
l'obligation d'avoir réformer la garde à
vue en préservant l'équilibré fragile
entre le respect des droits individuels
du gardé à vue
mais aussi des victimes et le respect
des droits de la société que nous sommes
chargés de protéger face aux craignent à
la délinquance
la clé de la réussite de cet équilibre
résidente des règles procédurales claire
excluant tout risque d'arbitraire ou de
laxisme
l'exercice qui nous incombe aujourd'hui
est donc très délicat
au surplus la navette parlementaire
entre nos deux assemblées devra être un
véritable marathon afin de permettre le
cas échéant conseil constitutionnel
d'effectuer son contrôle dans les délais
impartis
en réalité ce calendrier pose également
une question de fond nous devons
réformer notre garde à vue en dehors et
préalablement à la réforme globale de la
procédure pénale c'est à dire avant même
que nous ayons mis en chantier la
nécessaire nécessaire refondation de
notre code de procédure pénale
la réforme que nous examinons doit 6
frayés un étroit chemin entre divers
intérêts souvent contradictoires elle
doit reconnaître que le mis-en-cause
puisse exercer les droits légitimes à sa
défense à cet égard la possibilité pour
le suspect d'être accompagné d'un avocat
dès le début de la garde à vue est actée
en posant ce principe dans la loi nous
allons tourner une page de l'histoire de
la procédure pénale de notes
pis elle doit donner les moyens de mener
l enquête sans entraves afin de
permettre la manifestation de la vérité
malgré la difficulté de la tâche des
services chargés de mener l'enquêté en
particulier dans un contexte où la
criminalité évolue où elle est sans
doute de plus en plus complexes nos
organisées souvent dimension
internationale nous devons donc éviter
que le déroulement de la garde à vue
puisse gêner ou entraver la mission de
l'enquêteur elle doit aussi accordé à la
victime les moyens d'être respectés et
protégés et éviter que dans les faits
elle est comme c'est hélas le cas le
sentiment que les rôles sont inversés
en d'autres termes quelles soient mises
en accusation tandis que l'auteur du
délit apparaîtrait comme une victime du
système qu'il faudrait protéger à tout
prix
et c'est là sans doute qui est un défi
très important nous devons donc veiller
à ce que nos concitoyens s'approprient
cette réforme et qu'ils y adhèrent en
ayant acquis la certitude que la vérité
celle des faits celle des préjudices
n'en sera pas la victime
en somme la certitude que la réforme
n'empêchera pas la justice de passer le
projet doit vous nous présenter monsieur
le ministre est un progrès le
renforcement du rôle tenu par l'avocat
lors de la garde à vue constitue
désormais un point consensuelle du débat
le président de la république lui-même
déclaré devant la cour de cassation le 7
janvier 2009
je le cite parce que les avocats sont
des auxiliaires de justice et qu'ils ont
une déontologie forte
il ne faut pas craindre leur présence
dès les premiers moments de la procédure
il ne le faut pas parce qu'elle est bien
sûr une garantie pour leurs clients
elle est aussi une garantie pour les
enquêteurs eux-mêmes qui ont tout à
gagner d'un processus consacré par le
principe du contradictoire
c'est là monsieur le garde des sceaux
une vision partagée le progrès qui n'est
perçue aujourd'hui que pour le gardé à
vue est également un progrès pour les
policiers les forces de gendarmerie
il n'y a pas de contradiction dans le
texte je crois qu'il n'est pas inutile
de réaffirmer avant d'aborder plusieurs
points essentiels je veux rappeler un
aspect doublement fondamental de ce
texte
tout d'abord la garde à vue fait pour la
première fois dans notre procédure
pénale l'objet d'une définition ensuite
elle ne peut être mise en oeuvre que
pour atteindre 6 objectif clairement
défini ses objectifs sont d'autant plus
protecteur que s'agissant de textes
pénaux
ils doivent recevoir une interprétation
restrictive
la garde à vue sur le fond ne peut
désormais trouver application que dans
les délits et crimes passibles d'une
peine d'emprisonnement
le déroulement de la garde à vue
présente désormais des droits nouveaux
ou plus étendue parmi ceux ci je
souhaite relever la consécration du
droit de se taire le droit de prévenir
un proche son représentant légal et son
employeur la garantie immédiate d'un
interprète pour la notification des
droits
la limitation de la force probante des
déclarations faites hors l'intervention
de l'avocat et l'extension de
l'assistance de l'avocat
ce dernier point est sans doute celui
qui fit l'objet de plus larges
commentaires
le débat sur la présence d'un avocat en
garde à vue est ancien il échoué jusque
alors sur l'une de nos traditions
juridiques celle d'une conception de la
procédure pénale selon laquelle le
contrat dit le caractère contradictoire
des phrases d'instruction puis de
jugement permettait de poser certaines
restrictions aux droits de la défense
lors de la phase policière
sans remettre en cause pour autant ni la
présomption d'innocence ni l' équilibre
du procès pénal lui même
incontestablement l'année pas écoulée a
fait voler en éclats les lignes de
fracture qui marquait traditionnellement
ce débat le droit à l'assistance
effective d'un avocat durant toute la
durée de la mesure est affirmé et
organisé de même et ce parallélisme est
important la victime pourrait être aussi
assistés d'un avocat lors d'éventuelles
confrontations
ces dispositions s'accompagne d'un point
important la résolution de la question
de l'accès au dossier
l'avocat peut ainsi non seulement dès le
début de l'instruction consulter le
procès verbal de notification du
placement en garde à vue de la
notification de ses droits mais aussi
les procès-verbaux d'audition qui sont
déjà réalisés y compris d'ailleurs le
certificat médical c'est un examen de ce
type a eu lieu l'avocat pourra assister
la personne en garde à vue dès le début
de la mesure
il pourra même poser des questions à la
fin de l'audition le texte va plus loin
dans la définition des possibilités qui
le rend ce domaine
ce dispositif novateur et pour moi
fondamental et équilibrée dès lors
qu'ils trouvent uniquement sa limite
dans les hypothèses où il serait t'il
légitimement porté atteinte au bon
déroulement de l'enquêté
ou à la dignité de la personne cette
annonce ans avec sagesse que l'assemblée
nationale a prévu un délai de carence de
deux heures pour tenir compte de la
situation concrète des barreaux est
donnée à l'avocat le temps de se rendre
sur les lieux où s'exerce la garde à vue
ici encore l'idée est de sécuriser le
processus et non de génie ou de
favoriser des uns ou des autres
il s'agit de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de contestation ultérieure du
processus de la garde à vue il est
renforcer l'effectivité du droit accordé
à la personne gardée à vue
en tenant compte de certains obstacles
susceptibles de retarder l'arrivée de
l'avocat sans que parallèlement
l'indisponibilité de celui ci soit de
nature à retarder une enquête qui
souvent acclament des diligences les
constatations rapide
nous notons enfin avec satisfaction que
la tentative de création d'un régime
d'audition libre sans recours nécessaire
un avocat était définitivement écarté je
ferai m'arrêter un instant sur la place
du juge et du parquet tout d'abord je
veux rendre hommage à la qualité du
travail accompli par les procureurs de
la république à la manière donc avec les
services de police et de gendarmerie
ils assument leurs responsabilités je
conseille aux besoins mes collègues qui
n'ont pas eu l'occasion de le faire de
visiter un tribunal de grande instance
s'est dit observer la permanence du
parquet le jour et la nuit
et le travail effectué par les
magistrats de ces unités c'est une tâche
extrêmement difficile
rempli de pièges qui peuvent ensuite
avoir des conséquences redoutables dans
les procédures et qui est effectué avec
un dévouement remarquable
cela aussi me paraît devoir être rappelé
dans ce texte il nous faut dans le
respect des jurisprudences de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et de
la cour de cassation trouver un
dispositif qui définissent le plus
précisément possible rôle du procureur
de la république ainsi que le rôle du
juge je ne m'engagerai pas dans un débat
dogmatique que sur ce point
essayons d'être pratique nous devons
mettre en place un dispositif juridique
qui fonctionne la spécificité française
a beaucoup été critiqué cette tribune
mais le parquet est la française a
souvent également démontré ses avantages
il ne s'agit pas uniquement de la garde
à vue mais du fonctionnement général de
la justice au surplus le débat sur
l'évolution du statut du parquet dans le
cadre de l'étude du prochain code de
procédure pénale sera ouvert je tiens
donc à rappeler que nous soutenons
processus d'intervention du procureur et
du juge tels que notre rapporteur l'a
rappelé en confiant les responsabilités
au procureur de la république dans le
début du processus et en faisant
intervenir le juge le plus rapidement
possible je rappellerai cela déjà été
fait que là c'est le dh n'a jamais
imposé que la garde à vue soit contrôlée
par un magistrat du siège
elle impose seulement qu'au delà d'un
délai variant entre trois ou quatre
jours une personne privée de liberté
soient présentés à un juge indépendant
et le conseil constitutionnel et la cour
de cassation n'ont d'ailleurs jamais dit
autre chose en matière de police des
gardes est il faut éviter que les
législateurs stigmatise la profession
d'avocat en préjugeant d'un mauvais
comportement je soutient ardemment
complètement le rapporteur dont son
souhait de partir de l'assurance que
l'avocat se comportera selon sa
déontologie en tant qu avocat et ancien
bâtonnier
je peux vous affirmer que cette réforme
est un véritable défi pour la profession
d'avocat cette dernière je m'y attends
que dans ce domaine une juste
rémunération lui soit reconnu et assuré
mais au-delà de cette question il ne
faut pas se cacher les difficultés que
rencontreront certains barreaux pour
assurer dans la pratique l'application
de cette loi et la satisfaction de ses
exigences
je ne doute pas néanmoins que la
profession prendra très rapidement par
dont les dispositions des initiatives
nécessaires pour qu'il en soit ainsi
les chers collègues nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le risque de donner un coup de
frein le lutte contre la délinquance
mené inlassablement par le gouvernement
ce serait un mauvais signal pour les
français qui nous disent tous les jours
leurs besoins de sécurité ce sera un
mauvais signal pour les délinquants qui
pourrait croire que tout est permis en
toute impunité
ce serait
un mauvais signal enfin pour nos forces
de l'ordre qui voyant leur efficacité
mis à mal pour des questions
procédurales nourrir est non seulement
un sentiment de lassitude mais pire
souffrirait d'une motivation des
motivations dans leur lutte quotidienne
contre la délinquance et puis enfin ce
serait également une injustice envers
les victimes d'infractions
nous devons également éviter de faire
une réforme pour rien je veux dire par
là que nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de mettre en place un
dispositif qui pourrait encourir dans
les mois qui viennent de nouvelles
sanctions soient du conseil
constitutionnel soit de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme sont
encore de nos plus hautes juridictions
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à une
réforme essentielle très attendu par le
sénat pour les raisons qui ont été
développées ce matin par notre
rapporteur
elle est cependant en raison de ses
objectifs techniquement complexe au nom
du groupe dont je suis le porte parole
je veux vous dire que la réforme que
vous nous présenter monsieur le ministre
nous convient elle parvient à un certain
équilibre entre les différentes
contraintes que j'ai évoqué un certain
nombre de dispositions qui nous semblait
initialement poser problème ont été
modifiées voire supprimer les apports dû
à la qualité du travail et de l'ecoute
la qualité d écoute de notre rapporteur
doivent être saluées vous l'aurez
compris mes chers collègues nous
voterons avec satisfaction le texte qui
nous est soumis merci françois pivert la
parole est à yves détraigne pour l'union
centriste qui bénéficient de 16 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
était c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
très attendu depuis un peu plus d'un an
c'est d'ailleurs la quatrième fois si je
ne me trompe que nous examinons la
question de la garde à vue
que ce soit au travers de questions
orales avec débats de propositions
doigts et enfin aujourd'hui avec ce
présent projet de loi
le sujet n'est donc nouveau ni pour
notre haute assemblée ni pour sa
commission des lois et surtout pas pour
ce rapporteur françois zocchetto qui a
déjà eu l'occasion d'intervenir est
d'approfondir cette question à
l'occasion des travaux que j'ai évoqué
un instant la réforme de la garde à vue
était devenu depuis plusieurs mois non
plus souhaitable mais tout simplement
indispensable et urgente
cela a déjà été rappelé la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 30 juillet
2010 faisait peser fait peser une épée
de damoclès au-dessus de notre tête
puisque sans intervention du législateur
avant le 1er juillet prochain la garde à
vue serait privé de base légale tut a
cité à cet évident amant inenvisageable
mais cette décision du conseil si elle
est sans doute celle qui a l'effet le
plus contraignant pour le parlement
n'est pas la seule décision ayant relevé
les insuffisances de notre système
actuel de garde à vue aussi bien la cour
de cassation que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ont rendu ces
dernières années plusieurs arrêts
rebonds les insuffisances du système
actuel le thème récurrent de ses
décisions
c'est généralement la présence et
l'assistance de l'avocat au cours de la
garde à vue
la jurisprudence de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme aborder cette
problématique sous plusieurs angles le
moment de l'intervention de l'avocat
avec les arrêts murray contre royaume
uni du 8 février 1996 et salduz du 27
novembre 2008 mais aussi la portée de
l'intervention de l'avocat au travers
des arts et diana ni pruskow rendus
respectivement en 2009 et 2010 mais
au-delà de ces aspects purement
juridique qu'il nous faut évidemment
régler la réforme de la garde à vue doit
aussi être l'occasion de faire évoluer
son usage au quotidien et de remédier à
certaines dérives qui ont pu être
relevés
tout d'abord comment ne pas être
interdite
et par le nombre de gardes à vue
prononcées chaque année il atteint des
records et les chiffres que l'on évoque
aujourd'hui doit nous faire réfléchir
près de 800 mille gardes à vue par an
aujourd'hui contre trois à quatre cent
mille il y a une dizaine d'années il
n'est pas question évidemment de
promouvoir une quelconque forme de
laxisme dans ce domaine la garde à vue
et il reste un acte de police judiciaire
bien souvent indispensable mais il faut
en faire une utilisation plus rigoureuse
qui tiennent d'abord compte de la
gravité des comportements en cause et
qui ne soit pas banalisée
non il faut le dire ce n'est pas normal
d'être placé en garde à vue pour une
simple contravention comme on l'a
parfois vu ces dernières années
le texte qui nous est proposée prévoit
donc que cette garde à vue n'est
possible ne sera possible
quelques jours une personne à l'encontre
de laquelle il existe je cite le projet
de loi une ou plusieurs raisons
plausibles de soupçonner qu'elle a
commis ou tenté de commettre un crime ou
un délit puni d'une peine
d'emprisonnement
cela paraît bien être la moindre des
choses
un débat a eu lieu en commission sur la
question du seuil d'emprisonnement qui
pourrait justifier le placement en garde
à vue et plusieurs collègues souhaité
qu'on ne puisse être placé en garde à
vue que si on encourt un emprisonnement
d'une durée supérieure ou égale à trois
ans je note que notre rapporteur a fort
justement rappelé au sujet de ce débat
un principe fondamental qu'il ne faut
pas oublier la garde à vue est d'abord
et avant tout créatrice de droits pour
la personne qui a été interpellée
augmenter le seuil conduirait à
augmenter mécaniquement le nombre des
personnes soupçonnées de faits graves
qui serait auditionné sans les garanties
prévues par la garde à vue et notamment
hors la présence d'un avocat
néanmoins et les débats en commission
est également mis en évidence prévoir
cette seule condition pour être mis en
garde à vue n'évacue pas n'évacue pas je
crois le débat sur la hiérarchie la
logique des peines prévues dans notre
code pénal entre les incriminations créé
il ya plusieurs décennies avec une
échelle des peines qui avait sa logique
à l'époque et les incriminations crée
aujourd'hui au coup par coup au détour
d'un article d'une voie nouvelle qui n'a
pas titre principal de caractère pénal
il y as c'est évident les incohérences
dans l'échelle des peines qui
justifierait que l'on toilette le
système pour que le fed encourir une
peine de prison qui peut justifier
juridiquement une mise en garde à vue
correspondent bien dans tous les cas un
acte d'une réelle gravité or force est
de reconnaître qu'il y à une telle
diversité dans l'échelle des peines
aujourd'hui qu'il n'est pas certain que
le seul critère de 2 d'un an
d'emprisonnement encourue suffise à lui
même à limiter la garde à vue à des
actes d'une réelle gravité
revenons-en aux aménagements qui ont été
apportées par l'assemblée nationale le
premier changement majeur concerne
précisément la question d'audition libre
afin de contribuer à la réduction du
nombre de gardes à vue l'article premier
du projet initial posait le principe
aujourd'hui absent du code pénal du code
de procédure pénale plutôt de l'audition
libre d'une personne suspectée du
caractère en fait subsidiaire de son
placement en garde à vue pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées précédemment
l'absence de reconnaissance de droits
suffisants pour le suspect entendu
librement et l'absence d'assistance de
l'avocat l'audition libre a été écartée
et comme notre rapporteur nous
approuvons cette évolution du texte
articles neufs qui encadre les mesures
de sécurité et les fouilles dont peut
faire l'objet la personne gardée à vue
l'assemblée avait prévu la possibilité
pour la personne qui se trouvait dans
cette situation de conserver je cite
certains objets intimes en contrepartie
la signature d'une décharge pour
apporter une réponse à la difficulté
soulevée par une pratique critiquée
notamment mais pas seulement dans le
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation des libertés pratiques
humiliantes et souvent inutiles
consistant à retirer par exemple
systématiquement les lunettes et les
soutiens gorge afin de prévenir
soi-disant tous risques d'agression de
suicide alors même que ce risque est en
réalité un film et que cette pratique il
faut le dire semble dater quand même
d'une époque révolue
notre commission a jugé que la garantie
apportée par l'assemblée devait être
renforcée et a prévu que la personne
devait en tout état de cause disposer au
cours de son est dit de son audition de
ses effets personnels est là encore il
s'agit d'une amélioration bienvenue dont
on s'étonne qu'elle n'ait pas été réglée
plus tôt cette idée
ménagement permettra de contribuer j'en
suis sûr un meilleur respect de la
dignité des personnes gardienne autres
aménagements importants liés à
l'assistance d'un avocat
les députés ont institué un délai de
carence de deux heures avant
l'expiration duquel la première audition
de la personne gardée à vue ne pourra
pas débuter le texte initial du projet
guen ne prévoyait expressément ni que
les auditions pourraient débuter sans
attendre l'arrivée de l'avocat ni
qu'elle ne le pourrait pas le silence de
la loi sur cette question essentielle
était donc source d'insécurité juridique
le nouveau dispositif précise bien la
situation sans remettre en cause la
suppression de l'audition libre
je voudrais à titre personnel cependant
attirer votre attention mes chers
collègues sur le fait que le délai de
carence de deux heures prévues pour
permettre dit salement l'avocat de
rejoindre pour prêt pour permettre à
l'avocat de rejoint les locaux de garde
à vue et pendant lequel l'interrogatoire
lé ne pourra pas commencer du mois en
règle générale risques dans certains cas
je le crains de nuire à l'efficacité de
l'enquète non pas quand on a affaire à
des voyous chevronnés
de toute façon ils savent comment se
comporter et si je puis dire
mais quand on a affaire à des
délinquants débutants qui parfois
reconnaissait sans difficulté le fait du
simple fait d'être conduits à la brigade
au commissariat de police
les deux heures de carence pouvant alors
mais j'espère me tromper
permettre à un suspect qui a réellement
quelque chose à se reprocher
d'échafauder un scénario qui retardera
l'apparition de la vérité je le dis à
titre personnel ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas un débat qui a eu lieu réellement au
groupe mais je vous livre mon avis il ne
faudrait donc pas selon moi que le
recadrage certes nécessaire des
personnes le contest de la garde à l'ue
ne nuise dans certains cas à
l'efficacité de l'en tête
au final les travaux de l'assemblée de
notre commission des lois ont permis
d'aboutir aujourd'hui un texte qui est
me semble-t-il bien mieux abouti que le
thé social
je voudrais également faire une
réflexion plus générale sur quelques
aspects qui suscite encore des
interrogations
tout d'abord les avocats sont devant un
défi important à relever ça a été
heureuse a été remarquée notamment par
mon collègue piller qui était à cette
tribune juste avant moi il va falloir
assurer sur tout le territoire
sur tout le territoire l'assistance des
centaines de milliers de gardes à vue
même si c'est plus glissant 1000 et là
il faut bien reconnaître que le risque
d'un traitement discriminant entre zones
urbaines et zones rurales existe bel et
bien
le risque j'espère me tromper une risque
il existe notre collègue mais zara eu
l'occasion en commission d'insister à
juste titre sur cet aspect le rôle des
barreaux sera déterminant mais il faut
reconnaître que certaines zones du
territoire vont être devant des
difficultés difficilement surmontable
chacun comprend bien la différence qui
existe entre un commissariats des
hauts-de-seine et une brigade de
gendarmerie isolé dans un village de
montagne en plein hiver
il est évident que dans certains
secteurs géographiques de notre pays
sera beaucoup plus difficile pour
l'avocat d'arriver dans les deux heures
du délai de carence que dans d'autres
secteurs notamment urbains certains pour
en tirer la conclusion qu'il faut que
les gardes à vue soient centralisées
dans les principales villes de ce
département
mais alors on irait vers deux catégories
de commissariats et surtout vers deux
catégories de brigades de gendarmerie ce
qui serait inacceptable
et là dessus nous devons être fermes si
nous voulons que la sécurité soit
assurée de la même manière sur tous les
points du territoire
et si nous ne voulons pas décourager
certains services de police ou de
gendarmerie
restons fermes sur la nécessité de
conserver le maillage national des
brigades et de garder partout des
brigades de plein exercice ou puisse se
dérouler les gardes à vue alors
évidemment ça nécessitera parfois des
travaux d'aménagement de certains locaux
et cela coûtera sûrement plus cher en
frais d'avocats je pense notamment à
l'aide juridictionnelle qu'aujourd'hui
comme rapporteur pour avis de plusieurs
années du budget des services
judiciaires à la commission des lois je
me permets d'insister monsieur le
ministre pour que les crédits
nécessaires soient bien prévu au bon
niveau et sans qu'on a il est prélevé
sur d'autres actions du même programme
ou des mêmes ou des programmes autres de
la mission justice ensuite
on a des difficultés pratiques si la
réforme que nous examinons aujourd'hui
était indispensable
va-t-elle assez loin sur certains points
certes ce garde des sceaux ce n'est pas
encore la grande réforme de la procédure
pénale que l'on nous annonce depuis
maintenant des années et je crains
d'ailleurs qu'avec l' annonce du débat
sur l'introduction des jurés populaires
en collectant en correctionnelle dès le
mois prochain nous avons appris cela
hier réforme qu'au demeurant peu de gens
réclament est à mon sens on continue
après cette loi un modifié par petites
touches notre droit pénal ce qui n'est
pas me semble-t-il la meilleure méthode
j'espère donc j'espère donc que nous
verrons bientôt arriver un débat de fond
sur l'ensemble notre procédure pénale
car ce débat est nécessaire
les nombreuses polémiques autour du
statut du parquet roller relancé par des
arrêts importants
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
que l'on ne pourra continuer à ignorer
ne sont qu'un exemple parmi d'autres des
questions que nous devrons réexaminer
ceci dit la réforme que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est la bienvenue
c'est pourquoi le groupe de l'union
centriste votera en faveur de l'adoption
de ce projet de loi sur lequel la
commission des lois et notamment son
rapporteur notre collègue françois
zocchetto a fait un excellent travail
merci dépeignent la parole et à notre
collègue virginie klès qui est apparenté
socialiste et qui dispose de neuf
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ont filmé
concernées je ne pense pas que ça vous
étonnera vraiment je ne partage pas
vraiment l'optimisme de notre rapporteur
et collègues zocchetto quant à l'avenir
et l'évolution d'un texte qu'il a lui
même qualifiée de largement un parfait
s'ils tentaient que cet avenir et cette
évolution reste entre vos mains
et quand je constate combien il a déjà
fallu d'énergie de volonté et même de
condamnations pour en arriver là nous en
sommes arrivés un tout petit pas pour
l'homme comme pour la justice en
l'occurrence
et pourtant c'était pas la lune qu'on
demandait pourquoi pourquoi fait-on
toujours tout le dos au mur contraints
et forcés après avoir été sourd et
aveugle à toutes les propositions qui
ont émané de l'opposition mais aussi des
professionnels et même parfois au sein
des rangs de votre majorité
quel que soit le texte et quelle que
soit la réforme
alors oui mille fois oui ce texte était
nécessaire indispensable la gauche et
d'autres que nous le disent et le
répètent sans avoir pour autant attendu
d'être condamnée par la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et sans avoir non
plus attendu l'avis du conseil
constitutionnel
oui mille fois oui les officiers de
police judiciaire tous les intervenants
ça n'a juste y sont aujourd'hui d'accord
pour travailler mieux ensemble
et vous savez ils le disent aujourd'hui
on sait que tout changement proposé
entretien au départ des inquiétudes
c'est normal mais si ce changement
annoncé est accompagné d'une vraie
concertation est un vrai débat avec les
professionnels concernés
si ce changement est expliquée voire
amendé en entendant leurs propositions
en entendant les acteurs et les
intervenants alors ces changements
peuvent prendre la pleine mesure de
l'efficacité et d'un réel consensus
alors oui oui et mille fois oui encore
les principes qui sont aujourd'hui
énoncés sur le papier sur le texte que
vous nous soumettez
sont indispensables mais telle
qu'énoncée seront ils efficaces
auront-ils la possibilité d'être
efficaces seront il applicable et seront
ils appliquer certains oui sans doute
tout ce qui est notification d'euros du
droit au silence le retour de la
notification du droit au silence
peut-être certaines fouilles humiliantes
seront elles éviter demain
le fait de pouvoir faire avertir son
entourage sera également sans doute
appliquer le fait de ne plus pouvoir
être condamné sur la base est simple
aveu notamment obtenu sans
l'intervention de l'avocat ce sera peut
être appliquée mais le reste leur est
laissée mois d'août et beaucoup douté de
leur application alors les raisons ce
nouveau ratage il me semble monsieur le
ministre que la façon de gouverner du
gouvernement qu'elle vous appartenez
certes depuis paix auquel vous
appartenez tout de même et de la
majorité à laquelle vous appartenez
depuis un bon moment
cette façon de gouverner dans
l'immédiateté
avec un calendrier qui est uniquement
liée aux échéances électorales et aux
faits divers des réformes qui ne sont
entamées que contraint et forcé une fois
de plus quand on est le dos au mur quand
on n'a plus le temps du réel débat né de
la concertation ce n'est pas le temps ce
n'est pas le calendrier de la politique
avec un p majuscule celle là doit se
faire sur le long terme
surtout quand on touche aux structures
mêmes de notre société et de notre
démocratie
surtout quand on touche à la justice et
la sécurité
nous attendions une réforme du code de
procédure pénale il nous vient un texte
réducteur d'affichage et chacun sait ici
que pas grand chose de concret
malheureusement non sortir à votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre et le
président de la république
particulièrement ont ce véritable don de
transformer tout ce qui aurait dû être
une grande réforme fondatrice de
nouveaux liens sociaux en des petits
textes minimalistes à visée électorale
électorales ou de mise en conformité
apparente votre gouvernement et le
président de la république
particulièrement ont ce véritable don de
transformer tout ce qui aurait dû être
un débat de fond un débat d'idées abeba
de société en affrontements inter
institutionnelle en affichage de réforme
en montant les uns contre les autres et
chacun à tour de rôle c'est ont assez
que l'assistance de l'avocat au gardé à
vue est rendu tellement obligatoire en
turquie qu'aucune déposition faite en
dehors de la présence d'un avocat ne
peut être versée au dossier de
l'instruction sans confirmation par la
personne des faits qui sont incriminés
et comme mon collègue mézard ce matin
avant moi je réaffirme mois que les
forces de sécurité que les officiers de
police judiciaire ne sont pas les
responsables de la politique pénale qui
est imposée à tous par votre
gouvernement
les gardes à vue abusives ou abusivement
malmenés ne sont que le résultat de la
politique de répression croissante
judiciarisation galopante d'accélération
des procédures judiciaires que même
votre gouvernement le nombre d'officiers
de police judiciaire a beaucoup augmenté
non pas parce qu'on a recruté par son à
diminuer le niveau de qualification
nécessaire pour mener une garde à vue
je pense gendarmes j'ai bien dit que ce
n'était pas eux les responsables
monsieur le président c'est le
gouvernement et la politique qu'il mène
qui en est responsable
mais oui le nombre d'officiers police
judiciaire qui parvenait des gardes à
vue aujourd'hui sont moins qualifiés qui
hier je suis désolé je suis désolé chers
collègues les gendarmes
oui ceci d'accord avec vous c'est qu'ils
se trouvent je trouve donc je trouve
simplement dommage qu'on diminue le
niveau de qualification de ceux qui font
des gardes à vue
la garde à vue est un moment extrêmement
important dans l' enquête et la garde à
vue nécessitant une formation
particulière à mon sens parce que c'est
un moment humainement compliqué parce
que c'est un moment important pour la
manifestation de la vérité et de
diminuer la formation des personnes
habilitées à mener des gardes à vue est
à mon avis dramatique pour notre société
est dramatique aussi pour les gendarmes
et les policiers et tous les officiers
de police judiciaire
et si on parlait un peu justement de
qualité ou de parler de chiffres de
performances et si on appliquer des
critères différents à ceux du privé pour
qualifier et pour quantifier le service
public
et si on donnait tout simplement les
moyens d'agir à ceux qui doivent d'agir
et si au lieu de s'intéresser au nombre
de gardes à vue
on s'intéressait par exemple au nombre
de gardes garde à vue qui ont mené à une
élucidation ou qui ont mené à une
condamnation
votre gouvernement monsieur le ministre
aime les chiffres personnellement je
déteste pas non plus mais à condition
qu'ils signifient quelque chose est en
tout cas aux chiffres je préfère moi les
notions de dignité de respect de la
présomption d'innocence qu'on oublie un
peu trop souvent d'indépendance de la
justice et d'équilibré des partis pour
arriver à ces objectifs là il faut s'en
donner les moyens
il faut à nouveau augmenter la
qualification des officiers de police
judiciaire qui maintenant les gardes à
vue il faut diminuer le nombre de gardes
à vue
la dignité impliqué on le sait ça a été
dit ce matin des réflexions à des
rénovations dans les locaux ça implique
des moyens financiers qui n'apparaissent
pas dans le texte de loi
si on veut que l'avocat même temps
présents puissent avoir accès aux
auditions quand elles qu'elles se sont
passées il faut augmenter la vidéo il
faut augmenter nombre de caméras
pourquoi ne bascule ton pas un petit peu
des fonds du fpd qui nous assènent un
certain nombre de caméras sur l'espace
public dans cet espace là des gardes à
vue
on a les moyens s'agit les affecter là
où il faut quant aux avocats
l'introduction de l'avocat dans l'
enquête et l'introduction du
contradictoire dans l' enquête avant que
le dossier n'a riche le juge
donc si c'est une très bonne chose ça
nécessite aussi pour être efficace une
égalité renforcé de tous les citoyens et
de tous les justiciables y compris
pendant cette enquête
et ça et ça ce n'est pas dans votre
texte parce que l'aide juridictionnelle
n'est pas là parce que les moyens ne
sont pas là savez vous combien la
justice aujourd'hui père à un avocat de
rennes qui devra aller à 2 heures du
matin à redon pour une garde à vue pour
assister un gardé à vue on va lui donner
71 euros c'est la misère c'est une
misère
et ben si aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est
les chiffres qui leur sont données savez
vous qu'il est aujourd'hui 115 avocats
du barreau de rennes qui sont
volontaires pour assumer des permanences
et pour aller effectivement assisté des
gardés à vue
je sais pas ce qui restera de ses 115
volontaires une fois qu'on leur dira que
pour aller de rennes à redon à 2 heures
du matin on leur donnera 71 euros savez
vous quel est le budget de la durée
dictionnaire en angleterre 3 milliards
d'euros en france dix fois moins
alors ce système va nécessairement
introduire une justice à deux vitesses
del'enquête qui sera devenu
contradictoires la justice urbaine la
justice rural la justice des riches la
justice des pauvres
c'était déjà une évolution bien entamée
avec la réforme de la représentation en
cours d'appel et le recentrage de la
possibilité pour les justiciables de
faire appel à condition d'être en zone
urbaine où il ya des grands cabinets
d'avocats et d'en avoir les moyens
voilà ce qu'il va advenir de ce texte
voilà ce qu'il va advenir des beaux
principes posés dans ce texte
et voilà pourquoi j'attends moi de voir
à minima ce que vous ferez de nos
amendements est ce que vous mettrez
comme moyen comme moyen pour aller vers
cette réforme qui était pourtant
essentielle est très importante
j'attends de voir ce que vous en ferez
avant de voter mais je suis assez
pessimiste
merci virginie klès et la dernière
oratrice inscrits 7 alima boumédiene
thiery rattaché au groupe socialiste et
qui dispose de huit minutes à
on va avoir monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président et mes chers
collègues
ce projet de loi relatif à la garde à
vue nous est présenté comme faisant
suite à une décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 30 juillet 2010 selon
laquelle les dispositions actuelles de
la loi concernant les conditions de
placement en garde à vue sont
inconstitutionnelles alors permettez moi
cependant de vous indiquer monsieur le
ministre que cela arrive quand même très
tardivement en effet il y a des années
que la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme confronte les exigences
conventionnelles aux pratiques et à la
procédure en matière de garde à vue et
rappelle le respect dû aux droits des
personnes gardées à vue et à sa défense
effective dans l'art et muret contre le
royaume uni du 8 février 96
la france aurait notamment dû réagir en
rendant effectif et concret le droit
pour le gardé à vue de bénéficier de
l'assistance d'un avocat
plus récemment dans une série d'arrêts
rendus contre la turquie et l'ukraine en
2009 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme est à nouveau intervenu pour
préciser le champ d'application de
l'article 6 de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme qui garantit le
droit à un procès équitable à la phase
antérieure du procès pénal
et c'est ainsi que la cour de strasbourg
a défini de manière précise les
principes directeurs applicables au
régime de la garde à vue
dans la continuité de ces arrêts de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
datant de fin 2009
j'ai d'ailleurs moi même déposé ici une
proposition de loi relative à la garde à
vue et dès janvier 2010 tirant ainsi les
conséquences de ces exigences
conventionnelles
ce texte n'a malheureusement pas abouti
car il était employé renvoyé en
commission
enfin avril 2010 il aura donc fallu
attendre que le conseil constitutionnel
rendre sa décision
2 juillet 2010 pour que vous daignez
enfin vous intéresser à la question
enfin il était temps plus que temps vous
avez dépassé on est vous avez en effet
déposé ce présent projet de loi le 13
octobre 2010 à l'assemblée nationale et
la france fut condamnée par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme le
lendemain le 14 octobre 2010 avec
l'arrêt brusque au puy le 23 novembre
avec l'arrêt france moulin
cette réforme de la garde à vue qui nous
est soumise aujourd'hui
ou devrais-je dire et vous m'excuserez
du terme mais c'est une vérité cette
réforme est au delà du fait qu'elle soit
très insuffisante et malheureusement
aussi très darty ve
en effet si les amateurs et sénatrices
d'europe écologie les verts se
réjouissent de quelques avancées
relatives au rôle de l'avocat lors de la
garde à vue et à la possibilité pour lui
d' assister son client lors des à
l'issue des auditions et des cons
fondation confrontation ce projet de loi
présente cependant de nombreuses lacunes
insuffisante et des incohérences
il semblerait que vous n'ayez pas
monsieur le ministre in fine est
absolument pas tenu compte de la
jurisprudence de la cour de strasbourg
qui pointent pourtant du doigt les
modalités de classement en garde à vue
celle relative à son contrôle et aussi à
son déroulement
tout d'abord j'aborderai ce qui me
semble essentiel le rôle controversé
accordé au procureur de la république
dans ce projet de loi le parquet
intervient à la fois au stade de
contrôle d'une du contrôle de la garde à
vue et de son renouvellement
il s'agit dans ce projet de loi de
reproduire une anomalie procédurales
pourtant dénoncée par tous les
magistrats eux mêmes qui dans le rapport
rendu par le conseil national de la
magistrature en 2008
considéré à 64% que les membres du
parquet n'étaient pas indépendants
les avocats juristes universitaires mais
aussi surtout la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme dans l'arrêt france
moulin et 23 novembre 2010 pose
clairement le principe selon lequel les
membres du ministère public français ne
sont pas indépendants et ils ne peuvent
pas être assimilés en matière de garde à
vue
à une autorité judiciaire au sens de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme seul le conseil constitutionnel
est restés frileux sur cette question de
l'indépendance et du procureur de la
république
et c'est sans doute pour cette raison
que le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez monsieur le ministre s'est
abstenu de résoudre cette question
pourtant essentielle
en effet des 79 la cour de strasbourg
indique pourtant que le procureur n'est
pas une autorité judiciaire indépendante
ce principe se rappelait récemment à la
france avec les arrêts medvedyev du 10
juillet 2008 puis du 29 mars 2010 pour
la grande chambre
le ministère public français ne dispose
pas d'une indépendance suffisante
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif et ses membres
ne sont pas des magistrats au sens des
dispositions conventionnelles qui
encadre la privation de liberté au vue
de l'arrêt france moulin précités il est
donc désormais difficile d'imaginer que
le présent présent projet de loi puisse
être adoptée en l'état sans qu'une
réforme du statut du parquet ou de ses
compétences soient aussi adopté et oui
permettez moi monsieur le garde des
sceaux de vous rappeler seulement un
paragraphe de cet arrêt du fait de leur
statut les membres du ministère public
en france ne remplissent pas l'exigence
d'indépendance à l'égard de l'exécutif
qui selon une jurisprudence constante de
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
compte au même titre que l'impartialité
parmi les garanties inhérentes à la
notion autonome de magistrat au sens de
l'article 5 paragraphe 3 il me semble
donc que les choses sont claires
en effet cet arrêt confirme la nécessité
d'une modification profonde de
l'organisation judiciaire française
et pourtant monsieur le ministre votre
projet de loi prévoit de son article 1er
l'insertion d'un nouvel article 62 5 au
code pénal qui dispose de manière
ostentatoire que l'oeil la gare de vue
s'exécute sous le contrôle du procureur
de la république
alors excusez moi je ne vois pas où est
l'avancé concernant la dépendance
les sénateurs et sénatrices écologistes
ont donc eu notamment cosigné une série
d'amendements consistant à supprimer
tout
ference au procureur de la république
dans ce projet de loi et à tirer les
conséquences de cette jurisprudence de
la cour de strasbourg de strasbourg il
est essentiel en effet que la garde à
vue puisse bénéficier des garanties
légales nécessaires et que son contrôle
et son renouvellement puisse être ainsi
être confiée au juge judiciaire
ce devrait être en effet les juges des
libertés et de la détention qui assume
dans ce texte le rôle que vous vous
obstinez à octroyer au procureur de la
république
mais pourquoi faites vous à ce point la
sourde oreille monsieur le ministre
pourquoi votre gouvernement souhaite il
s'affranchir des exigences
conventionnelles et jurisprudentielles
en matière de droits et de libertés
fondamentales autant proclamer ici ou
efforts que vous aspirez à ce que la
france se retire peut-être du conseil de
l'europe
enfin ce serait ridicule ne vous faites
pas ainsi autant attiré les foudres des
ré professionnels du droit des
associations des universitaires et des
instances de strasbourg un autre élément
est tout aussi choquant dans ce projet
de loi le seuil de déclenchement de la
garde à vue dans la définition de
l'article 1er du présent texte d'un
ennemi du présent texte donne de la
garde à vue
il est prévu que le placement en garde à
vue puisse intervenir dès que l'on
soupçonne que la personne ait commis ou
tenté de commettre un crime ou un délit
puni d'une peine d'emprisonnement
il me semblait monsieur le ministre vous
avoir entendu argué du fait que ce
projet de loi avait également pour objet
de diminuer le nombre des gardés à vue
or vous le savez près de 800 mille
gardes à vue ont été décidées en 2009
pensez vous que ce seuil au delà de
porter atteinte aux droits des personnes
concernées et notamment de la
présomption d'innocence permettent de
faire en sorte que ces chiffres
diminuent
évidemment que non eh bien au contraire
c'est pourquoi sur ce point les
sénateurs et sénatrices écologistes
refusent le placement en garde à vue de
personnes soupçonnées d'infractions
mineures et donc les gardes à vue
abusives
ou excessives nous sommes donc
favorables à ce que ce seuil de
placement en garde à vue porte soit
porté à trois ans d'emprisonnement et
nous nous associons également ici aux
amendements du groupe auquel nous
appartenons
enfin je tiens enfin à vous indiquer que
je regrette évidemment le caractère bien
trop limitée qu'accor de ce texte à
l'intervention de la vodka
je prendrai ici l'exemple de la thur
durée insuffisante accordé par l'article
6 du projet doit à l'avocat pour
s'entretenir avec la personne gardée à
vue
cela présuppose qu'en trente minutes
maximum
et quelle que soit la complexité de la
faire un avocat et le temps d'échanger
avec son client de l'écouter sur
l'exposé de situation de prendre
connaissance du procès verbal ou d
autres pièces du dossier
or vous n'êtes pas sans savoir monsieur
le ministre que cette durée est
excessivement réduite sera évidemment
insuffisante dans les affaires les plus
complexes tant en ce qui concerne la
prise de connaissance des faits que des
nombreuses pièces présentes dans le
dossier de la personne gardée à vue
cela porte donc atteinte atteinte aux
droits à la défense effective en
particulier au recours effectif à la
vodka
j'espère donc que sept amendements que
nous avons déposés consistant à modifier
l'article 6 du projet a augmenté cette
durée d'entretien avec l'avocat sera
adopté lors de notre débat vous aurez
donc compris que les sénateurs et
sénatrices écologistes considèrent que
ce deal ce texte ne fait en réalité que
feindre de s'aligner sur des
prescriptions conventionnelle et
constitutionnel mais dissimule
finalement son manque d'ambition
derrière des dispositions vraiment
inefficace est vraiment incomplète
merci merci alima boumediene thiery seul
ministre vous souhaitez répondre
voilà
la discussion générale est close et vous
avez la parole monsieur le garde des
sceaux
merci beaucoup monsieur plusieurs jurés
en quelques mots répondre à l'ensemble
des orateurs d'abord remercié et les
membres du sénat d'avoir participé
activement à cette discussion générale
qui est en effet est la bienvenue alors
beaucoup d'entre vous ont souligné les
avancées et que ce texte fait faire à
notre droit et notamment les avancées
concernant l a mise en oeuvre de
libertés publiques fondamentales
garanties par la constitution
d'autres ont préféré faire d'autres
choix dans leurs interventions et et
surtout nous dire que ce texte n'était
pas bon ce qui est leur droit
je respecte mais j'ai trouvé parfois un
peu excessif et bien entendu quand on
est trop excessive dans la critique
après c'est moins efficace donc je
voudrais revenir sur un certain nombre
de points qui ont été avancées d'abord
plusieurs dans plusieurs orateurs
un bouquin cm sur adjani monsieur mézard
gbagbo bédié reste aux mêmes viennent de
nous dire mais pas possible vous avez
agi sur la contractent vous attendez
trop vous auriez dû faire cela depuis
longtemps alors on peut s'interroger à
des faits non mais c'est probablement
appui alors que vous avez entendu
beaucoup vous avez pu faire plus tôt
plus on n'en fait pas assez
il avait fallu présenter un code de
procédure pénale ou alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu mais il me faut me laisser
finir parce que si on ne saura jamais
pourquoi vous me critiquer c'est très
embêtant quand on sait pas quel est
l'objet de la critique
donc moi je veux simplement dire qu'il
est tout à fait exact que des travaux
extrêmement lourds sérieux ont été
menées pendant plusieurs mois par des
groupes de travail notamment un groupe
de travail composé notamment
d'universitaires
deux parlementaires de la majorité et de
l'opposition
tout à fait on travaillait elles ont eu
raison parce que code de procédure
pénale ça concerne tous les français
ils ont eu raison et moi je les félicite
de savoir dépasser et de temps en temps
de petites divisions partisanes parce
qu'un code de procédure pénale ça
concerne tous les français et il est
tout à fait bien que tout le monde
puisse y travailler parce que demain ce
code s'appliquera quel que soit le
gouvernement en place
alors pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a
pas déposé ce texte dans son ensemble
devant le parlement
tout simplement parce que pour des
raisons de temps nous sommes tenus cela
a été dit pratiquement pas tous les
orateurs à prendre des mesures sur la
garde à vue avant un le mois de juillet
je dirais même avant la fin du mois
d'avril qui est devant nous donc très
vite et on n'a pas le temps de pouvoir a
discuté de l'ensemble
mais pour ma part je ne verrais que des
avantages à publier l'ensemble des
travaux qui ont été faits par ce groupe
de travail et qui servirait à alimenter
les débats qui ne manqueront pas d'avoir
lieu sur ces sujets alors cité n'est
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement n'a pas
attendu les dernières décisions du
conseil constitutionnel de la cour de
cassation ou de la cour de strasbourg
pour réfléchir à la question
le comité léger d octobre 2008 avait
réfléchi sur cette affaire et des textes
ont été pris pour améliorer les droits
de la défense ces dernières années par
exemple la loi de mars 2007
renforçant les équilibres de la
procédure pénale a rendu obligatoire
l'enregistrement des gardes à vue en
matière criminelle
ce qui constituait une première avancée
enfin et surtout les questions à
résoudre sont particulièrement complexes
elle s'agissant notamment des exigences
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme de strasbourg boumédiene thiery
qui était très exigeant sur les délais
c'est parfaitement que c'est une
décision du 8 février 1996 un muret côte
royaume uni qui a permis à la cour
d'indiquer que violer l'article 5 de la
convention le refus pour une personne
gardée à vue dans une affaire terrorisme
d'avoir accès à un avocat pendant les 48
premières heures de la mesure donc 1996
on a tous eu le temps de commencer à
réfléchir
et si on n'est pas parvenu à l'aip 8
c'est parce que les questions sont
pratiques et il ya cependant rue ede des
occasions quatre ans plus tard s'être
inceste us 4 ha ça fait 2000 et le 15
juin 2000 il y à une loi sur la
présomption d'innocence qui était
présenté et défendu par manu guigou qui
est un très bon texte et qui malgré
cette jurisprudence européenne a
maintenu l'absence d'avocat pendant 48
heures en matière de trafic de
stupéfiants et de terrorisme
mais je suis empêché personne de
critiquer le gouvernement
je trouve que vous êtes dans votre rôle
dans le mien c'est de le défendre
donc j'assume mon rôle avec enthousiasme
et sans aucun problème
de même mais il faut bien tout mettre
sur la table
sinon on n'arrivera pas à discuter la
démocratie ça peut être apaisée on peut
se dire des choses me faut tout mettre
sur la table et de même la loi du 4 mars
2002 défendu par madame lebranchu tout
en maintenant de report de l'avocat
pendant deux jours dans les bâtiments de
ce trafic de stupéfiants et de
terrorisme
faciliter le placement en garde à vue en
exigeant non plus des indices de
culpabilité mais et des raisons
plausibles et donnait aux délais de
trois heures aux enquêteurs pour mettre
en oeuvre le droit du gardé à vue à
faire informer approche ou à être
examiné par un médecin si et je rappelle
c'est fait c'est pas pour critiquer et
ceux qui étaient là avant moi ou avant
ce gouvernement c'est simplement pour
montrer que ces affaires sont complexes
demande réflexion et doivent
nous conduit à analyser dans le détail
ce que veut la la cour de strasbourg
donc les récentes décisions de ne mettre
pas le gouvernement le dos au mur
elles permettent simplement maintenant
de savoir clairement ce que sont à la
fois les exigences constitutionnelles et
conventionnelles et elles permettent
d'éclairer le gouvernement et le
parlement sur ce que doit être un le
contenu de la réforme et le gouvernement
pour préparer ce texte et s'est astreint
cette pâture très facile mais à intégrer
dans le texte l'ensemble des décisions
du conseil constitutionnel de la cour de
strasbourg ainsi que de la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation alors
une autre question qui a été soulevée
par de nombreux orateurs le rapporteur
lui-même en a parlé et a expliqué arnaud
paquet de la commission elle pas choisi
d'encadrer la garde à vue en fixant un
seuil minimal d'emprisonnement encourue
partage bien entendu sur ce point l'avis
du rapporteur
mais d'autres orateurs qui sont ici dans
la salle dessus bézarde ciani ben borvo
souhaite instaurer un seuil de 1 en 3
ans ou 5 ans suivant le cas en dessous
duquel la garde à vue elle serait
impossible
je crois que la commission des lois du
sénat a eu tout à fait raison car cela
aurait conduit à priver les enquêteurs
d'un moyen d' enquête qui est essentiel
qu'il ne doit pas être banalisé et comme
l'a très justement dit monsieur pilet je
crois qu est ce qui est important dans
le texte c'est aussi que pour la
première fois on donne une définition de
la garde à vue et selon des critères
précis
c'est l'article 1 qui réalise cela et je
crois que c'est tout à fait de nouveau
sur l'interprétation de la jurisprudence
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme plusieurs d'entre vous considère
que notre projet
nous permettrait pas de nous mettre en
conformité avec la jurisprudence de la
cour de strasbourg
je ne veux pas revenir sur ce sujet je
me suis très longuement expliqué sur ce
point dans mon intervention liminaire et
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir au moment
de la discussion des articles sur ces
points mais je veux rappeler est que la
france n'a jamais été comme l'a souligné
b se pile est spécifiquement condamné
pour une garde à vue réalisées sous le
contrôle du parquet quoi qu'il faut le
dire parce que c'est la réalité ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas de
problème et je veux redire notamment à
verdun boumédiene thiery qui semblait
d'une sévérité extraordinaire mais
malheureusement complètement en dehors
de la cour des décisions de la cour de
salzbourg que oui
le procureur les pas une autorité
judiciaire au sens de la cour européenne
de strasbourg
oui oui c'est vrai et je les dis ce
matin dans mon intervention et je ne
leur dis sans problème ce n'est pas le
sujet et nous sommes d'accord pour dire
avec la cour de strasbourg que
l'exigence commerciaux d'elle avec des
queues un délai court qui est située
entre autour de 48 heures est dépassé
l'autorité judiciaire telle qu'elle est
définie par la cour de strasbourg doit
être un juge du siège dans les 48
premières heures qui va contrôler la
garde à vue c'est cela un sujet ou bien
on laisse seuls les forces de police
menée en abris ou bien on fait au met en
place un autre contrôle la france a
choisi et on devrait plutôt être fier de
ce choix on doit plutôt être fiers ce
choix on a choisi de faire contrôler
dans les 48 premières heures la garde à
vue par un magistrat personne n'a jamais
dit que le procureur n'était pas un
magistrat
la constitution la constitution et bada
boumédiene thiery
je suis obligé de vous le dire s'impose
à vous comme un mois et on est heureux
d'avoir une constitution parce que quand
il ya près de constitution il ya pas de
liberté
donc la constitution et le conseil
constitutionnel dans les décisions
je passe une contre de son ancien
présent s'impose à tous même à vous
madame rappelé dans le considérant m je
vous en prie alizés et bien je vais
continuer je vous remercie de me séparer
de ma gentille et je veux simplement
dire que le conseil constitutionnel dans
son conte sidérante 30 de sa décision de
juillet dernier a rappelé le texte de la
constitution en france
nul ne peut être arbitrairement détenus
c'est la baisse corpus et l'autorité
judiciaire gardienne de la liberté
individuelle
l'autorité judiciaire est composé des
magistrats du siège et du parquet point
final
donc nous avons fait le choix clair et
je crois que c'est un bon choix de faire
confiance au procureur parce qu'il est
un magistrat
madame je peux entendre plein de choses
mais ne pas vouloir reconnaître cela
c'est vraiment vouloir se boucher les
yeux et lorsque par exemple en
grande-bretagne on confie un officier de
police
le contrôle de la garde à vue pendant
toute la durée de la garde à vue qui
peut aller dans certains cas très
spécifique donc c'est pas la généraliser
des cas jusqu'à 26 jours sans qu'il y
ait d'autres contrôles que celui de
l'officier de police
honnêtement nous sommes dans une
situation qui du point de vue de la
garantie des droits est bien meilleur et
je dois dire que
en mai traduisant comme nous le faisons
la jurisprudence de la cour de
strasbourg dans un autre droit s on y
est obligé par notre constitution
l'article 55 c'est tout à fait vrai je
garde des sceaux mais je de jeux d'éveil
mais c'est notre système à nous qui est
très particulier et qu'on ne retrouve
pas dans tous les états européens et il
suffit de voir ce qui vient de se passer
dans le parlement de westminster il y a
quelques jours qui a rappelé la
souveraineté absolue de la chambre des
communes
face à la cour de strasbourg
cela peut être discuté c'est quand même
une décision qui a été voté par le
parlement
chez nous il ya bien longtemps que
probablement parce qu'il a été aussi
professeur à strasbourg et carré de
malberg nous a expliqué que le
parlementarisme absolu s était dépassé
donc nous sommes dans un cadre et qui
est défini avec deux garantit une
promotionnelles et une constitutionnelle
et je crois très honnêtement que nous
avons réalisé une des meilleures
garanties qu'ils soient des droits dans
un lagarde
alors je veux pas revenir sur l'ensemble
des choses qui ont été dites et je
remercie les orateurs qui ont bien voulu
indiquer qu'il y avait des avancées dans
ce texte rien n'est parfait
on n'est pas dans le règne de la
perfection absolue c'est évident mais il
s'agit simplement de progresser vers un
mieux et l' équilibre qui est construit
entre l'exigence de l'enquète qui doit
trouver et les responsables et des
crimes et des délits et en même temps
l'équipe qui doit être réalisé avec
respect des libertés fondamentales
c'est un nouvel équilibre c'est une
avancée ça nécessite de la part
notamment des forces de gendarmerie et
de police
de vrais efforts je veux ici leur rendre
hommage on a besoin d'elle il s'agit pas
de les désarmer
pas du tout et je crois que personne ne
l'a dit et je ne reconnais bien
volontiers je veux le dire parce qu'elle
nous parle à deux nous adressons aussi à
l est mais que très bien actuellement ça
va demander des changements
la présence de l'avocat dès la première
minute
c'est un changement fondamental je sais
beaucoup d'entre vous m'ont parlé des
moyens pour rémunérer les avocats je
sais parfaitement que cette question est
posée c'est parfaitement qu'il faut
qu'on la réole pour diverses raisons les
négociations n'ont pas pu être entamée
avant que le texte ne soit voté à
l'assemblée nationale
nous avons eu des premiers contacts nous
en aurons d'autres
je sais aussi et qu'il faudra trouver
des modalités techniques par exemple et
que je suis comme beaucoup d'entre vous
ont dit bois très opposés à tout
regroupement des gardés à vue
je veux véritablement que toutes les
brigades de gendarmerie notamment bas
puissent avoir des op ji puissent faire
leur travail et soient des brigades de
plein exercice alors et moi je suis
ouvert et prêt à discuter avec les
barreaux à toute modification technique
je sais par exemple d'après ce que j'ai
compris mais je peux me tromper
avec aujourd'hui le choix de l'avocat
est libre est mais qu'est ce qui n'est
pas libre
c'est le payement de l'aide judiciaire
et qu'il faut je suis prêt à négocier
avec les barreaux pour trouver de bons
systèmes de telle façon que le libre
choix de l'avocat et qui peut se trouver
à quelques kilomètres avec les limites
des ressorts dans un autre tribunal plus
proche des brigades de gendarmeries les
gardés à vue que les avocats qui se
trouverait dans une ville chef lieu
d'arrondissement ou plus grandes îles
scilly à des nécessités de trouver des
mesures techniques
on les trouvera je suis tout ouverts à
ces mesures là pour permettre que le
libre choix puceau s'effectuer dans ce
sens de l'efficacité
je sais parfaitement qu'il y a
parfois de kilomètres à faire je dois
dire dantesque
très honnêtement d'aller de rennes à
redon en deux fois deux voies
c'est un plaisir toujours renouvelé
mais que je l'invite à aller chez
monsieur mézères enfin non non non non
non aux ordres ça va très bien leur nom
s'arrête parce que il y à des
restaurants gastronomiques mais monsieur
bédard et encore de la neige
monsieur s'il y est je tiens tout à
binche attend oui mais j'attends que ce
soit plus précis sur lui dit que j'aurai
le renseignement ce sera oui je voulais
simplement dire que faut qu'on regarde
tout cela est que il faut aussi qu'on
arrive à indemniser les avocats dans des
conditions qui soient dignes de bettié
de la réforme que nous faisons et tout
en préservant les finances publiques que
ce qui n'est pas très facile sur le
délai de carence
j'avais compris et quelle était la
position de la plupart d'entre vous
rappelle que je soutiendrai un
amendement ramenant à une heure ce délai
de carence pour laisser le plus de temps
à lenquête voilà et après eh bien vous
voterez et quoi enfin c'est quand même
pas plus compliqué que ça c'est la
démocratie et je veux terminer ses
explications
or en rappelant que ce texte constitue
une avancée vrai dans notre droit une
avancée dans la protection des droits
la plupart d'entre vous l'ont souligné
et je remercie je vous remercie de
l'avoir fait madame borvo cohen seat
elle a fait et je la remercie d'avoir
fait la plupart des orateurs 1 qui sont
ici nos fins et c'est très bien ainsi
parce que un texte comme celui ci il
faut qu'il soit approprié par le plus
grand nombre possible de français pour
pouvoir faire vivre notre procédure
pénale qui serait ce à tous sans
condition partisane de majorité ou
d'opposition
donc c'est vrai ce texte constitue une
vraie avancée dans deux domaines
je veux son idée et il faut vraiment
pour avoir un droit pénal moderne
abandonné clairement la culture de
l'aveu et à l'est vers la culture de la
preuve
ça nécessite des changements et tout ce
que l'on fait dans le domaine de la
politique de la police technique et
scientifique va dans ce sens il faut
apporter la preuve des choses c'est le
rôle de deux enquêtes qui doit à faire
émerger la vérité de la preuve
et puis et c'est aussi bien entendu des
droits nouveaux inconnus la dignité de
la personne qui est mise en garde à vue
qui est considéré correctement dans ce
texte et l'assurance que la personne
placée en garde à vue pourra bénéficier
des conseils et de l'assistance d'un
avocat dès deux premiers instants de la
garde à vue il ya donc là je crois
matière à débattre mais bat hier à
avancer ensemble vers un renouveau de
notre procédure pénale
et bien je vous remercie sur le ministre
de cette réponse
alors tout d'abord avant de passer aux
motions de communication je rappelle que
la commission de la culture et la
commission des affaires étrangères ont
proposé des candidatures pour deux
organismes extraparlementaires la
présidence n'a reçu aucune opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
l'article 9 du règlement
en conséquence ces candidatures sont
ratifiés je proclame catherine tasca et
monsieur louis duvernois en tant que
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'institut français et madame claudie de
nos pages en tant que membre de conseils
du conseil d'administration
d'orientation stratégique de l'institut
français j'informe le sénat que la
commission des lois a fait connaître
qu'elle a procédé à la désignation des
candidats aux éventuels commission mixte
paritaire chargée de proposer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi organique et
du projet de loi relatifs au défenseur
des droits
cette liste a été affichée conformément
à l'article 12 alinéa 4
règlement et sera ratifié ces aucune
opposition n'est fait dans le délai
d'une heure alors maintenant nous allons
passer à l'examen de la motion tendance
à opposer l'exception d'irrecevabilité
monsieur jean pierre michel et les
membres du groupe socialiste apparentés
et rattachés ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous numéro 65 tendant à
opposer l'exception d'irrecevabilité au
texte en discussion
je rappelle qu'en application du dernier
alinéa de l'article 4 du règlement seul
droit à la parole sur cette motion
l'auteur de l'initiative ou son
représentant pour 15 minutes maximum
un orateur d'opinion contraire pour 15
minutes maximum
le président ou le rapporteur de la
commission saisie au fond et le
gouvernement
la parole est à son auteur monsieur
jean-pierre michel pour la motion merci
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux mais chers collègues la
réforme qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui est une réforme qui est
présenté alors que le gouvernement a
véritablement le dos au mur puisque le
conseil constitutionnel a fixé au 1er
juillet la date limite pour mettre en
oeuvre une nouvelle législation de la
garde à vue donc
l'épée de damoclès est sur vous monsieur
le ministre mais entendu dans tous mes
propos votre personne n'est pas en cause
ou les d'arriver au ministère mais
depuis 2007 le gouvernement aurait pu
agir il ne l'a pas fait il n'a pas voulu
le faire il n'a pas pris les moyens de
le faire et pourtant les avertissements
n'ont pas manqué ici même au sénat
plusieurs débats ont eu lieu
le président de la commission des lois
d'ailleurs plusieurs fois mis en garde
au gouvernement il faut le dire que si
le gouvernement ne faisait rien et bien
elle la commission des lois agir et
qu'il était temps alors après que faire
mais qu'il était temps mais tout ceci
n'a pas été entendu et tous ces signaux
tous ces appels
se sont heurtés à l'attitude fermée et
hautaine de votre prédécesseur qui nous
a renvoyés à nos chères études
prétextant que les arrêts de la cour
européenne ne concernait pas la france
mais des pays plus ou moins barbare
comme la turquie
c'est ce qu'ont entendu en commission
des lois et je suppose qu'elle tu veux
en cela les avis de son ministère et
pourtant
et aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
d'ailleurs je le dirai tout à l'heure
vous essayez de
si j'ose dire de finasser un peu
notamment sur le rôle du parquet
alors on y reviendra très bien mais on
verra ce que dit très exactement la
jurisprudence européenne
elle ne dit pas ce que vous prétendez
qu'elle dit ça j'en suis absolument
persuadé alors je ne rappellerai pas
toutes les décisions quand eu lieu
depuis au moins le 10 juillet 2008 alors
dilué 2008 medvedev
alors mme en commission à meuh non ça
nous concerne pas comment monsieur mais
et cetera et cetera bon voilà alors il
faut attendre le 23 novembre 2010
l'arrêt moulin pour que la le procureur
de la république de constitue pas une
autorité judiciaire indépendante
on ne parle pas de magistrat le terme
n'est pas employé il ne nous regarde pas
le procureur de la république ne
constitue pas une autorité judiciaire
indépendante seule autorité à même de
décider le renouvellement d'une garde à
vue
sic ce n'est pas ce que vous proposez ce
n'est pas sur la commission propose
c'est inconstitutionnel et je vais le
démontrer
la réforme donc intervient dans un
contexte particulièrement je dirais
incohérent
en effet il est totalement incohérent
parce que obligé parce que dans
l'urgence proposer une réforme de la
garde à vue qui n'envisage pas le rêve
de la procédure pénale ont lâché ben ali
quand où on ne peut pas dire que la
garde à vue sera sur un certain mode qui
est différent de l'ancien je le
reconnais monsieur le rapporteur
alors je suppose que le reste de la
procédure pénale sera aussi différentes
qualités aujourd'hui il ya ici deux
cents pages qui étaient là où sont elles
que sont elles devenues
on n'en sait rien et peu importe bon
tout ça s'envole dans le vent de
l'histoire mais tout de même
et aujourd'hui vous dites vous même
monsieur le ministre comme nous n'avons
rien prévu
que nous n'avons rien prévu durable je
n'ai pas les moyens d'appliquer la
réforme alors les discussions commencent
et bien moi je commence une négociation
pour savoir comment les locaux de garde
à vue seront équipés et comment les
avocats pourront être rémunérés et
cetera et cetera
tout ceci n'est vraiment pas sérieux et
n'est pas à la hauteur de la question
mais je lui ai dit tout à l'heure et je
le redis ce n'est pas à vous que je
m'adresse particulièrement et
personnellement vous le savez bien
alors trois mots peuvent qualifier
aujourd'hui l'actuel l'état de
l'autorisation françaises relatives à la
garde à vue c'est la confusion la
complexité et les dérives et notre
législation n'est pas dans ce domaine à
la hauteur de ce qu'elle devrait être
dans un état de droit
elle est en retrait par rapport à
beaucoup d'autres étapes plus proches et
cela d'ailleurs je n'invente pas celle
étude de législation comparée qui a été
fait par le sénat le 17 février 2010 je
crois qu'il a largement démontré
et lorsque nous sommes allés à à berlin
ou en italie mon cher à porter nous
l'avons également pu le constater cette
situation a valu à la france d'être
condamnée à plusieurs reprises comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ce qui
la grande-bretagne confiseurs c'est pas
si grave
bon nous on considère que c'est
autrement vous qui êtes un européen
convaincu
vous considérez sûrement touché très
graves d'être comparé d'être condamné
par la commission européenne des droits
de l'homme d'autres aussi plus ou moins
mais aussi par le conseil fonctionne
elle est enfin par la cour de cassation
qui finalement quand même compris
qu'elle devait bon ce maître je dirais
dans le droit fil de l'histoire
mieux vaut tard que jamais il faut
d'ailleurs rappeler à propos de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
que si la france entendu 25 ans après
avoir signé en 1950 la convention pour
la ratifier en 74
elle n'a accepté les recours quand 81
merci monsieur robert badinter
essentiellement en raison de l'absence
de réglementation sur la garde à vue
avant 1958 puis de la faiblesse des
garanties qui aurait été introduit dans
le code de procédure pénale or
le texte proposé aujourd'hui à mon point
de vue est un texte a minima et qui
encourt plusieurs critiques quant à sa
cohérence avec les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel et les filles non
conventionnelles et ceci sur trois
points que je vais très rapidement
énuméré le premier point c'est
l'audition libre alors l'audi 100 lits
ont été initialement prévu on a beaucoup
discuté ici
il revient pas elle était abandonnée
comme tel par l'assemblée nationale
et elle est réapparue dans un article 11
bis
or aucun droit à l'aide accordée à la
personne auditionnée par le politique
par la police enquêteurs même si la
durée maximale de la présence des locaux
de police n'est pas fixée on arrive à un
régime sans droit contraire aux
exigences du conseil constitutionnel de
la cour opel droits de l'homme et de la
côte la station et le risque est grand
d'une dérive vers un régime comme a dit
relatives à la grande hâte à la garde à
vue
voilà et un régime sans aucun droit
alors afin que cette audition répondent
aux exigences minimales de l'article 6
de la convention européenne
nous avons proposé et nous proposerons
un certain nombre d'amendements afin
d'encadrer cette audition afin de les
rendre conformes aux exigences
précédemment visée mon ami alleanza y en
a parlé tout à l'heure ses amendements
ont été rejetés par la commission des
lois malheureusement j'espère qu'ils
seront aujourd'hui acceptée car c'est
certainement un cas de censure vous me
direz si le conseil de censurer qu'un
article dans le courant du mois de juin
ça ne serait pas si grave
on se passe qu'est d'audition libre mais
il ya autre chose il dira également les
régimes transitoires germinal est
organisée terrorisme qui sont laissés
intacts
on y touche absolument pas et à cet
égard vous n'hésitez pas à écrire avec
quand même certains dont je trouve pas
le mot français que leur conformité à la
constitution a été réaffirmée par le
conseil constitutionnel dans sa décision
du 30 juillet 2010
or cela il faut totalement faux car le
conseil qu'en sus elle n'a pas examiné
cette question au fond mais la
persistance par le gouvernement a ignoré
totalement la jurisprudence établie par
la cour européenne droits de l'homme
ce quiz la pathologie résultat ces
régimes ne sont pas traités et la france
r toutes ses chances d'être condamnée à
strasbourg également sur ce point mais
surtout troisième point le projet de loi
confiée au procureur de la république
autorité de poursuite les pouvoirs
donnés les placements en garde à vue de
prolonger la mesure d'en contrôler le
bon déroulement de sauvegarder mais
aussi de limiter les droits de la
personne gardée à vue et le texte abouti
à une confusion des rôles alors que
plusieurs arrêts et déjà l'arrêt
medvedyev d'ailleurs avait dit que la
personne arrêtée ou détenue d'en
présenter d'autres présentés devant une
personne qui a des garanties requises
d'indépendance à l'égard de l'exécutif
et des parties ce qui exclut notamment
qu'il puisse agir par la suite qu'il
puisse agir par la suite contre le
requérant
or même si on parle pas aujourd'hui 200
les dépendances le progrès la république
et l'autorité de poursuite qui
poursuivra ensuite dans le reste de la
procédure
tout au moins telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et elle qui a été présenté
d'ailleurs par votre prédécesseur dans
la réduc à décembre 2010 la cour de
cassation reprend à son compte cette
interprétation
selon elle le ministère public ait pas
une autorité judiciaire au sens de
l'article 5 alinéa 3 de la convention
dans la mesure où ils ne présentent pas
d'une part les garanties d'indépendance
et d'autre part les garanties
d'impartialité car il est partie
prenante
la dernière décision de la cour
européenne l'arrêt moulin alors est
beaucoup plus claire se les rappeler
tout à l'heure et il dit que le
procureur ne remplit pas les 41
dépendance pourrait qualifier à exercer
des fonctions judiciaires c'est à dire
des fonctions de contrôle de la liberté
individuelle
la personne qui est placé en garde à vue
il s'agit bien là des décisions
judiciaires et non pas d'une décision de
sécurité le placement en garde à vue et
conditions de sécurité il peut
appartenir au procureur de la république
tout le reste fait du judiciaire c'est
le contrôle des libertés publiques et
des libertés individuelles et donc il
est essentiel aujourd'hui de repenser
totalement l'architecturé du ministère
public
en effet dans l'arrêt du 29 mars 2010 la
cour avait nuancé mais tout de même et
sa position était confirmée dans l'arrêt
moulin
dix ans que l'indépendance compte au
même titre que l'impartialité
en mai les garanties à la notion
autonome de magistrat
en outre la cour rappelle que les
garanties d'indépendance à l'égard de
l'exécutif et des parties est une
notamment que les magistrats puissent
agir par la suite comme le requérant
dans la procédure pénale
c'était le cas à l'évidence du procureur
de la république décor dès lors la cour
considère que le procureur le ministère
public ne remplissait pas en latics un
paragraphe 3 de la constitution des
garanties indépendante exigé par la
jurisprudence
pour être qualifié de juge ou autre
magistrat
on emploie le terme habilité par la loi
à exercer des fonctions judiciaires
et je soutiens que tout ce qui concerne
le contrôle des libertés individuelles
ce sont des fonctions judiciaires et je
ne sont pas des fonctions policières ou
des fonctions de sécurité
donc elles ne peuvent pas être exercée
par le procureur de la république
ainsi le rôle actuellement reconnues au
parc et autorisé la prolongation de la
garde à vue confirmé par le projet de
loi est contraire aux positions prises
par la cour de strasbourg
ça me paraît d'une lumière aveuglante le
rôle confié au parquet exige donc de
passer par une modification de
nomination de ses membres ainsi que leur
régime disciplinaire
et pourtant et partant dans un
renforcement des compétences du csm
cette réforme c'est vrai un pic une
révision constitutionnelle de la
composition et des compétences du cfl
qui sont fixées par l'article 65 de la
constitution
ce dispositif d'ailleurs a été voté par
nos deux chambres à la suite d'une
réforme engagée en 1998 par monsieur
jacques chirac après le rapport qu avait
confié à une commission présidée par
monsieur pierre truche mais pour des
raisons politiques de l'époque sur
lesquelles je ne reviendrai pas ce
projet de loi ce projet de loi qui avait
été adoptée par les deux chambres n'a
pas été soumis au congrès et donc n'a
pas été voté il faut d'ailleurs à mon
avis reprendre les principes de la
réforme inaboutie soit d'une part l'avis
conforme du csm sur les nominations des
magistrats du parquet et d'autre part la
compétence du tsl pour statuer en tant
que conseil de discipline
un consensus serait aujourd'hui possible
j'en suis persuadé ce fait révision mais
évidemment puisque vous êtes restés
sourds pendant quatre ans à tout ce
qu'on vous a dit à tout les tout ce qui
a été dit nous a prévenus qu'un jour ça
allait arriver que vous auriez le
couperet qu'elle est tombée le 1er
juillet place de la concorde est bien la
guillotine sera là et dont vous n'avez
pas le temps vous dit de faire la
réforme constitutionnelle parce qu'il
faut réduire le congrès à versailles etc
etc et bien
excusez moi de vous dire monsieur le
garde des sceaux vous y êtes très mal
pris vous d'autres vous y êtes très mal
pris le préalable à tout et même le
préalable à une réforme d'ensemble de la
procédure pénale telle qu'elle était
envisagée dans le rapport dans le pré
rapport de madame alliot marie que nous
avons examiné en commission des lois
très scrupuleusement avec mon collègue
jean rené lecerf le préalable était de
lire tout le monde de tout le monde
des procureurs généraux de séton présidé
la commission léger et cetera et cetera
c'était une réforme des magistrats du
parquet qui leur rend une indépendance
dans leur nomination et dans leur
discipline vis-à-vis du pouvoir exécutif
voilà vous l'avez pas fait et
aujourd'hui vous êtes là évidemment mais
monsieur le garde des sceaux
malheureusement personne ne peut se
prévaloir de sa propre turpitude
or c'est bien de cela dont il s'agit
on sait bien de cela dont il s'agit
aussi et dans la tente de cette révision
indispensable et préalable à tout récent
de la procédure pénale à toute réforme
d'ensemble
nous avons déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements qui propose de substituer
le juge des libertés de la détention au
procureur de la république pour tout ce
qui concerne le régime de la garde à vue
après la décision initiale de placement
cette décision est la moins mauvaise
durée est la moins de monde est ce parce
que le juge de la détention et des
libertés à mon avis est présente pas
aujourd'hui toutes les garanties pour
exercer cette mission d'abord qu'est ce
que c'est que ce juge par qui est il
nommé il devrait être nommé en conseil
des ministres le juge d'instruction
c'est pas le cas il peut être déplacé
pas de changer
il peut être placé par le président du
tribunal dans notre tâche dans le
tribunal
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui ils
regardent des dossiers très rapidement
des affaires célèbres ont montré à quel
point
dans certains cas il avait manqué aux
devoirs de sa charge
parce qu'il n'avait pas de temps parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas les dossiers et
aujourd'hui on veut bah oui en vue de
confier cette tâche
et puis certains nous disent mais ne le
fait pas parce que il va être débordée
et le joueur d'autant plus loft à partir
du 15
une première route encore par une
décision du conseil constitutionnel
eh bien il faudra que ce juge des
libertés a y contrôler toutes les
hospitalisations d'office ou les
hospitalisation à la demande d'un tiers
dans les différents hôpitaux
psychiatriques dans un petit département
comme le nôtre
d'après les psychiatres que je connais
ça fait à peu près 3 4 déplacements du
juge de vesoul à l'hôpital psychiatrique
par semaine
allons bon comprenne qui pourra et ils
feront ce qu'ils pourront le disais tout
à l'heure
même si la réforme est votée comment
sera t elle appliquée je n'en sais rien
ces amendements malentendu enfin
malentendus non pourquoi bien entendu
c'est un amendement a été repoussé en
commission des lois
peut-être mes chers collègues que vous
aurez la sagesse de ne pas suivre votre
rapporteur qui pourtant est très sage
d'habitude mais là je crois pas qu'il a
été beaucoup
et sinon bah vous montrer une loi qu'ils
encourent à la censure du conseil
constitutionnel
ça ne s'est pas à mon avis l'ombre d'un
doute
alors le gouvernement n'a pas voulu
s'interposer sur ces questions attend il
a décidé de passer en force il a décidé
de passer outre
eh bien monsieur ni je vous pose la
question que se passera-t-il
que se passera-t-il si le conseil
constitutionnel saisi rendra le mois de
juin avant le 1er juillet une décision
déclarant non conforme à la constitution
plusieurs articles de ce projet de space
2 est loi avant sa promulgation
vous me direz si j'agis des régimes
spéciaux et de l'audition libre on
pourra s'en passer fera un petit toit
comme ça qu'il s'agit du rôle du
procureur dans les prolongations
les dérogations
les demandes que l'avocat ne viennent
pas et tout toutes ces petites
dérogation qui ont été placés je suis
pauvre à la demande des syndicats de
police tu es bien tout votre texte au
bras à l'eau alors je fais appel à vous
mes chers collègues de la majorité c'est
parce que vous voulez c'est parce que
nous voulons non plus non plus donc vous
voteriez cette exception
d'irrecevabilité
j'en suis convaincu et puis le
gouvernement nous convoquera à
versailles très rapidement puisque le
texte est là il est pas besoin de
revenir devant l'assemblée devant le
sénat et puis après nous reviendrons ici
et dans l'urgence nous voterons une
réforme qui enfin viendra debout je vous
remercie
merci jean pierre michel nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir ou en savoir plus
sur la réforme de la garde à vue notre
site internet publicsenat.fr merci de
votre fidélité et à très bientôt sur
public sénat